the covert 19 pandemic has forced
governments around the world
to borrow and spend at an almost
unprecedented rate
[Music]
between april and june america alone has
borrowed three trillion dollars
the largest amount borrowed in a single
quarter since records began
the rise in public debt has been unlike
anything we've seen in recent history
in the past economists have warned
against high levels of borrowing
but new thinking suggests much higher
levels of debt
might now be sustainable the fact that
there's been such a dramatic change in
the consensus
makes some people nervous how much of a
cause for concern should the world's
rising public debt be
[Music]
governments have borrowed to finance
their spending for hundreds of years
at the end of the napoleonic wars in
1815
britain's debt was 164 percent
of gdp and after the second world war it
was even higher
at 259 percent of gdp
historically governments have borrowed
for a few main reasons
probably the biggest one was to fight
wars but in the past
100 years or so governments have
increasingly used their debt
as a way to try to keep the economy on
track
to raise money governments issue bonds
to investors
these are in effect ious that are repaid
over a fixed term
with interest at a rate that depends on
the length of the bond
how desirable these bonds are to
investors depends on the country's
credit worthiness
they tend to be very safe assets with
governments you can usually count on
getting your money back
once a bond has been uh sold by the
government out into the market
it can be swapped and traded as many
times as people care to
and that gives you a sense of how
markets view the creditworthiness
of the government
government bonds are bought by many
different investors
including pension funds hedge funds
banks and individual investors
as well as a country's own central bank
and local government
foreign governments also buy bonds the
biggest foreign holders of america's
public debt
are china and japan
if you have a safe asset that everyone
will accept like us government bonds
you can sell those bonds in a crisis get
dollars
and then use that to make sure you don't
get into trouble so there's quite a lot
of potential buyers out there for
government bonds
and really they could end up all over
the world
government's willingness to issue bonds
and increase public debt
has changed over time after the sky-high
debts of the second world war many
governments were wary of going further
into the red
but they continued to borrow and in the
1970s
this was blamed for high inflation a lot
of economists spoke to governments and
said
the reason you're facing these high
rates of inflation is because you're
borrowing so much
it's adding too much money into the
economy for the economy to easily absorb
and it's pushing up prices
that really ushered in a sea change in
the way that governments think about
debt
and so the use of borrowing as a
macroeconomic tool
slowly petered out until we got to the
global financial crisis
now it's official we are in a recession
major financial institutions have
teetered on the edge of collapse
and some have failed in the rich world
the financial crisis pushed public debt
from 74
to around 105 in the decade following
the financial crisis
and in emerging economies it rose from
roughly 35
to 48 of gdp this ballooning debt
caused political panic with some
governments pursuing strict austerity
to try to bring their budget deficits
down during the decade that followed
but it didn't go entirely to plan
by about 2014 the lessons of that
experiment began to be pretty clear
and what we learned was austerity
uh in a time of economic weakness hurts
economies so much
that it basically doesn't do any good
the economy becomes so weak
that you're not earning enough in tax
revenues to make it worth it
these problems with austerity led to new
thinking
in 2019 former imf chief economist
olivier blanchard gave a game-changing
speech
he argued governments could borrow far
more than previously believed
i think the fact that there's been such
a dramatic change in the consensus
makes some people nervous but at the
same time it wasn't a rash decision they
made it was heavily influenced by what
was going on in the world around them
blanchard observed interest rates on
government bonds have been falling
making it cheap for some governments to
borrow money
[Music]
at the same time the economy was growing
take america the rate of nominal gdp
growth
which is gdp before it's been adjusted
for inflation
has generally been higher than interest
rates for the past 30 years
this matters because as long as gdp is
growing
faster than the country's debt is
accumulating interest
and governments keep additional
borrowing in check
then a nation can effectively grow its
way out of debt
at no fiscal cost mathematically it's a
very straightforward point
but when you're explaining this to
governments and saying
this is how it goes that ends up being
quite a powerful thing
[Music]
not even a year after blanchard gave his
speech
coronavirus emerged in wuhan and the
greatest exercise in public borrowing
for generations began
government borrowing hit a record 55
billion pounds
the loaning public debt around 300
billion or 16
of gdp but not every country
can borrow its way through the pandemic
almost
every government has found it easier to
borrow now
than it was 30 or 40 years ago but the
difference between
a rich country and a poorer country
which doesn't have a long record of
borrowing
on foreign markets those places can't
get the same
interest rates it's a source of
significant inequality in terms of
how countries face this pandemic that
some places can borrow almost as much as
they want to support their economies and
others can
[Music]
borrowing on this scale is not without
risk for anyone
you owe us a lot of money what as
there's always the threats that interest
rates could rise again
economists aren't entirely sure why
these rates have been low for so long
in general interest rates on mortgages
government bonds
or savings accounts are driven by demand
if the desire to save is high then
interest rates will be low
as banks or governments issuing bonds
don't have to tempt investors with
favorable rates
[Music]
there are several factors driving the
desire to save which might be keeping
interest rates down
the aging population might be one cause
as people
tend to save for retirement and pension
funds by government bonds
and fear of global financial instability
may also play a part
causing investors to seek safe assets
like bonds
we can't be completely sure why exactly
it's happened and that matters because
if you can't be certain why it happened
in the first place
you can't say for sure that it's not
going to reverse itself at some point in
the future
uh which would be a big deal you know if
interest rates suddenly soared
then all the countries that had
accumulated a lot of debt would suddenly
be in very big trouble
despite these risks the pandemic has
left many countries with no
option but to keep borrowing
to cut deficit spending now while the
global economy is still crippled by the
pandemic
would inflict lasting damage but how
much
and how long countries can continue to
borrow is unclear
and the colossal debt built up in the
past six months
will be one of the greatest legacies of
the pandemic
i'm ryan avent the economics columnist
at the economist
we've written a series of articles that
cover the basics on a range of economic
topics
and how the latest thinking about them
is evolving you can read more at the
link opposite
thank you for watching
you